mark my words and i hate to say it but
i'm making the big prediction right now
i'm sounding the alarm i'm screaming
from the rooftops
and i have good news and i have bad news
the good news is that you're getting a
heads up and you'll have some time to
prepare the bad news is that it's
actually happening it's imminent it's a
mathematical certainty and it's going to
affect absolutely everyone
this is global and keep in mind that i
am from the united states i'm filming
this on may 27 2022 this will definitely
affect the western world but it's going
to affect the global population as a
whole
the cost of everything is about to
skyrocket far more so than it already
has and there are going to be food
shortages throughout the world the likes
of which are going to be straight up
horrifying and it's already underway
i am sounding the alarm like i said it's
late may but this is going to become
apparent for all who have eyes to see
in the next let's say month by the end
of june and certainly by the end of july
you will start to see that there are
many products that you'll struggle to be
able to purchase because they won't be
available and the cost of everything
will continue to go up far more so than
it already has now there are a variety
of reasons why all of this is happening
and i'm convinced that it's not
happenstance now between
30 trillion dollars in debt which is so
astronomically high because that's all
i've done they just printed printed
printed that eventually leads to
inflation the cost of everything
increasing
but there's another factor which is the
cost of fuel
the
everything we purchase is shipped by
whether it be truck train or automobile
or or airplane
everything runs on fuel so as the cost
of fuel goes up everything goes up
and
none of this
is
i don't think it's an accident but let
me just tell you what's already happened
the very fact that joe biden on day one
canceled the keystone pipeline which
that in itself
should have told
said everything day one cancel us from
being able to drill our own oil and even
the last few days i'm seeing senators
out of alaska
talking about how their land lease to
drill under their own ground was just
mysteriously canceled and is going to
expire in june
by the cancelled by the biden
administration this has never happened
before guys
what is that about and the fallout of it
is going to be extreme
also the cancellation of the petro
dollar if you're not aware the the
global currency of trading oil is done
in the us dollar it's been done so since
like 1978
under president nixon but long story
short that's done with now
and you are now seeing that in itself is
going to have a dire impact and it
already is because now you're seeing the
russian ruble the firm of currency
skyrocket like all of this guys was
going to happen true economists or
experts in the economy understood this
yet the whole media is just radio silent
on like oh well you know this is just
incompetence or something guys this is
not incompetence but never mind my
conspiratorial you know insinuations
here don't and don't believe anything i
have to say research this stuff so
inflation through the roof oil through
the roof and now
food shortages which are coming from a
variety of reasons so
you've heard a lot of things about the
ukraine fiasco and how wheat and
everything is grown there well the
united states doesn't get their wheat
from from ukraine or anything for that
matter but a lot of the the rest of the
world does and that wheat is not only
used to feed people it's also used to
feed farm animals
so like that in itself is creating like
a double whammy on that front now if
you're not seeing what's happening in
sri lanka you should look it up because
this is what's going to happen in many
other places
and soon
practically overnight they made a law
that says everything all food must be
grown organically
fertilizers are now outlawed well this
gave farmers no time to pray prepare and
they said it would take at least a year
well they didn't do that hence why
there's a massive food shortage now i
like to eat organic as much as i can but
the reality is that having nearly 8
billion people on this planet you cannot
feed everybody if you're not using
fertilizer at least as of today
and yet they're
overnight changing this up now go look
at the riots happening in sri lanka
because that's what's going to happen
elsewhere
um okay also a complete supply chain
disaster if you're not aware of what was
happening in shanghai with the lockdowns
for the last couple months
it's mortifying
but in that process you had more than a
thousand tankers cargo ships
parked offshore unable to load or unload
because of these lockdowns
well those thousand ships contain
absolutely everything under the sun
and it's going to create a supply chain
nightmare the likes of which we've never
seen
there's something called the bullwhip
effect which is where you have a hiccup
and supply chain it takes about 60 days
for things to carry over in some
circumstances at least globally
so that is why i am predicting that by
the end of june and let's say by the end
of july certainly certainty um you will
see the effects of this and it's already
happening like i was just trying to buy
underwear on amazon my favorite pair i
won't tell you what
and i like i couldn't find it in my size
same thing with white undershirts
couldn't find any of them it's been like
this for some time and so everything we
saw happen because of cove and all the
lockdowns things shutting down all of a
sudden you can't get things like you
used to and the prices go up for things
you that are available right
you're about to witness that
even worse now okay like this is
a a recipe of a perfect storm of things
are happening all at once and by the way
if this monkey pox thing becomes a real
issue if this becomes like the next
global pandemic or whatever so to speak
you will have lockdowns throughout the
world longer than they were with covid
like if this monkey posting is the real
deal
it has a two to three week incubation
period before you have any symptoms and
then once you have symptoms they can
last two to four weeks
in other words you will have lockdowns
the likes of which
do not compare to kovid and with all
these things happening all at once
throughout the world you will have the
economic disaster which i fear is coming
in fact i think it's coming regardless
of the monkey pox thing
the powers that be in this world
are telling us it's going to happen you
have biden in the world economic forum
saying that short food shortages are
coming they're talking about
transitioning to a digital currency in
the future and that there's you know the
great reset which was once called a
conspiracy like two years ago year and a
half ago is now fact
you can read about on time magazine
they're open about it this isn't some
nonsense the world economic forum is
actively saying it and now i'm seeing
the biden administration saying almost
everything that the world economic forum
is saying
add these things together do your own
research but the end result
is
suffering for everybody that there is
going to be
changes in our normal lives where
you didn't want to believe was possible
in our lifetimes and it shouldn't be
happening i'm convinced it's not
happenstance
but regardless between
the food shortages between the cost of
everything going up between supply chain
issues all of this is going to become in
my opinion the leading story in the next
month or two right now is the calm
before the storm and this gives you the
opportunity to prepare like i've done
not everyone is going to be able to
afford to do what i'm about to suggest
but if you can i highly recommend it
which is that you buy things
in bulk
that you know that you're going to need
forever whether it be toilet paper
kleenex socks and underwear your
favorite toothpaste or deodorant
anything you can think of the cost of
all of everything is going to skyrocket
whatever the reasons and because people
will debate this i've already made some
various comments on things going
happening in the world and people can
debate all they want never mind the
debate part the reality is that the cost
is going to continue to go up right so
which means that you'd be better off
buying things in bulk and buying things
that you may
may not be able to get in the future
back in
march 14th of 2020 i made a video
predicting things to come and it turned
out i was right about several of them
one of which was the purchasing panic i
predicted that before that became a
headline in the news i saw on social
media that people were buying things up
like toilet paper and other things and
some people thought that was silly at
the time but i'm like well it doesn't
matter if it's silly everyone's doing it
and you do not want to be last right we
all saw what happened so now is your
time to jump on it and by the way i'm
not spreading fear guys you know a few
people are going to see this throughout
the world half my audience is
international and and it doesn't matter
like they need to hear it fear or not
like this is reality and it reminds me
of a i use this analogy by the way i
shared this five days ago on my patreon
subscribe start on locals follow me
there guys you can't share everything on
youtube nowadays but now i'm making more
of an edited version for here but i made
an example it sounds kind of silly but i
think it's very applicable we've all
seen the movie titanic and there's a
scene after they hit the iceberg where
the officers the engineers and captain
they all met and they were discussing oh
my god it's gone over you know five
bulkheads you know it's definitely gonna
sink it's it's a certainty and that fool
was like oh this is the titan it can't
sink
and the guy's like uh it's made of iron
uh i assure you it can it's a
mathematical certainty that's what this
is like
enough things have happened and if you
understand how supply chain works you'll
understand the fallout that will come
from it um and there's no reason to to
that it's not gonna to think that it's
not gonna happen like we all wanna
believe it and like oh just kind of hide
under the covers and hopefully the
problem goes away
that's not happening in this in this
situation
bad times are ahead and this is not a
doom and gloom video
i am optimistic that the future is
bright in that in the long term good
will prevail but right now
some dire times are ahead now that said
good comes from everything in the face
of evil and suffering the best times are
possible and this is an opportunity for
people to shine and be their best some
people will be the worst
but the reality is that
look i hate to say it but it's like that
strongest survive thing there was many
people who ridiculed me for my video in
march of you know 2020 saying like hey
go buy stuff people like this isn't true
and you're spreading fear you're gonna
make it worse
well i didn't run out of toilet paper
and others did and i'm not gloating i'm
simply saying that i do spend a lot of
time researching things and although i'm
speaking off the cuff in this video and
not piecing together a presentation like
i normally do i don't really feel like
it this makes me depressed and bothered
and i'm working on my next video on
atlantis which would be super
fascinating by the way and i'm also
going to miami next weekend you're
welcome to come i'm going with phil
demers the walrus whisperer doing a
demonstration outside miami's aquarium
all good things and i can't wait to move
on to positive stuff
but the reality guys is that
things are about to change unbelievably
quickly
it's imminent and it's going to be
readily apparent in the next couple
months and it's going to continue to get
worse over the next few years until
ultimately the u.s dollar completely
crashes and the powers of b get to
implement their digital currency which
is what they're saying they're gonna do
that's the path forward
oh
man i know it sucks to hear in all this
guys but i'm sounding the alarm i know
it's imminent i rather not make this
video at all but i have a responsibility
with the following that i do not
everyone's going to listen to this video
so i encourage you to share it with
others or at least if nothing else do
your own research and communicate it to
whoever will listen because it's
happening whether you like it or not the
reasons it's happening are debatable and
i didn't include everything there's
other things to share but regardless
here we are
my name is jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright insight
hit the like button subscribe i have
many videos to come follow me on patreon
subscribe star and logos if you're able
to support me there
um that will enable me to be able to
speak truth and share things on
platforms that allow it i know patreon
is shady but like i'll you know i'll be
there as long as they let me but
anyways i'll close this up thank you all
for your time good luck and remember
like embrace a positive mentality
go outside pet your dog tell people you
love them like you know the world is
what we make of it and there are things
happening beyond our control but you can
still find light in the face of darkness
i know it
i'll close it up there take care
everybody